let's go next to our caller from the 317
area code who's calling today from
317. hello
david this is melinda and i just started
recently
watching you and thank you so much for
last night and helping me get through
the
election i just want to put that out
there i would have made it through you
made it
fun listen i barely made it through the
rnc
i didn't hear you say again i was barely
able to make it through the republican
convention
i know uh and the night before i've been
watching i was like i was flipping
through the station trying to figure it
out
but what i want to say is that i'm new
to all of this i never was wanting to be
into politics up until now you know and
lately it's like i'm losing so much
sleep
with you know i'm just so scared that
we're to wake up one morning and we're
going to have foreign soldiers on our
soil because
it just feels like he's weakening the
the country it's scary um
it's like i used to be so proud to be an
american a black american and now
it's you know um i'm getting to the
point where
i had heard a caller ask what is the
worst case scenario i started to hang up
because
it's pretty much my answer worst case
scenario was
what my nightmare has been so my
question is
with him doing all of this where he
uh is constantly breaking the law and um
not abiding by the rules and
why don't they and and i'm dummy to this
right now
and just learning why can't they just
all get together
and put him out with even knowing the
next four years
with what could come with him being in
office again
why why don't they just clean the white
house out with all of his people
and his move around why is he even able
to
even run for president again
okay so linda here this is a great
question so when you say why don't why
don't they just remove him who's the
they you're talking about
the the it's a lot of republicans i'm
sure
they're they're scared um the democrats
it seems like they're scary
i don't understand why they don't the
politicians just don't get together
and remove him out of there why was he
even allowed to even run again with
everything that's going
on okay so let me explain that this is a
good question because it's
you're coming into this and you're
applying logic to a situation that's not
logical so
uh trump was impeached by democrats in
the house
and then there was a trial in the senate
there's a majority of republicans in the
senate and the
and the republicans decided they weren't
going to convict donald trump so the
reason they didn't do it is because they
don't want to it's political
republicans have decided either it would
be bad for them or it would be bad for
their party or whatever
or they don't think trump did anything
wrong so the
the democrats can't remove him because
you would have to
through impeachment convict in the
senate republicans have a majority
they voted to acquit you could then
remove trump via
the 25th amendment if trump's cabinet
determined that he was unfit to serve
there'd be a special mechanism under the
25th amendment to remove him
republicans at trump's cabinet don't
want to do it so this is how we end up
at linda
that in 10 weeks we can remove him if we
vote him out
that's the way we do it
okay i'm doing everything i can my
little trump change i tried to
uh donate and um i'm
influencing my family to vote vote we
gotta vote like we've never voted
before yes um i just encourage everyone
that's listening to
just please vote get get out there tell
your family
um because it just and that was another
question if there's
how how does our vote count if they're
saying electoral
votes electoral votes
and i'm from indiana and it's like we're
red state and i'm like
everyone i talk to i don't see how we're
read yet i don't know how electoral
votes work i've
tried to google it look it up and see
how that works i
understand the basic of it is that that
state has this many electoral votes
i i kind of understand that part but
if the majority of the people that i see
a lot of people and i know there are a
lot of people that
are for republican diehard republicans i
get it
but at this point it's like let's just
do what's best for the nation period the
country
um i i'm i'm just
really scared and i thank you so much
for your broadcast
and and dumbing it down for people like
me
um to understand um i thank you so much
and i'll try to watch the show tonight r
and c
tonight i'll try but sometimes it just
gets so to the point where you just want
to puke because
even i see all the bad
stuff that's going on around here it's
like it's crazy
all right linda i appreciate the phone
call thank you so much
glad you're newly politically engaged
very important to be doing so
that's going to do it for calls today as
always
sincere apologies that i was not able to
get to everybody
but we will take calls again that's my
promise to you